what was the difference in going back
home and shooting sort of local boy
makes good if you go back home you shoot
there I'm sure people were incredibly
accommodating in wisconsin vs i don't
know if you've ever shot in LA yeah i
mean i think from the start we were
always in the shoot in wisconsin I when
I first started writing the script it
was we had a specific house in mind that
we wanted to film the the majority of
the film at so we like we were never i
never even researched la at all and in
regards to fill me what you need to do
to film him we were going back to
wisconsin and once we got there yeah it
was very i was awesome shooting there i
mean obviously with just connections at
different locations I mean shooting
inside of a pharmacy you know shooting
at a corporate restaurant corporate
restaurant chain and then several other
places and we got the proper releases
and I worked out very very well yeah I
mean it was not to because we had we had
released the permits drawn up and
contacting these individuals to lot of
shooting there there at the locations
and they just was like yeah no one even
I mean there's no one that really said
get lost or we think about it everyone
was pretty much almost everyone was on
board as soon as we said we're making a
movie I don't you think we told everyone
the movie was about we didn't know so
have you ever shot anything in LA an
indie project huh no I mean I I
personally have not made anything i mean
i've helped i was i just showed up to
help i don't know if you can call when I
didn't help you that's already stood
there um it was more or less to watch
what was going on but uh uh yeah i've
only been only been once to an actual
set other than that I've never I've
never been on a set o other than in your
own
our film and and the short sweet may
that's that's it actually that's not
sure I was i I was an extra one
commercial like many many years ago the
syringe commercial was a shot here yes
and what I just remembered so that was
interesting but any observations I don't
know what I mean I learned a lot from
watching individuals but I was actually
just right in the majority of time that
I was there until they're like I get
back in there um no I'm sure thing um
Bobby ona was the cinematographer unset
there who's a fantastic sound of tires
for and I walk up to him I was like
hopefully we work together one day he's
like yeah sure but yeah I mean I haven't
really had much experience with sets
other than work on this guy so when the
second feature comes out sounds like you
both wanted you guys yes June dis yo yo
wow that's old iron in six minutes do
you think it will again be back home or
I think so i think will depend a little
depending on what i have i've written
two additional scripts and depending on
which one we can find funding for or if
i finish another one another woman i'm
working on but we're looking for funding
now and one would take place most likely
in Wisconsin but the other one would
take place here so let me just a ton of
sketch ideas Tuesday don't see what
happens fun ton of sketches written and
short so yeah I'm open to anything I'm
just along for the ride so how are you
looking for funding or you
gene people I don't think we've reached
that point yet I said yeah we've been
swamped with the releasing this okan
walk so that mean there's virtually very
little time to do much anything else
since we have no no consistent we have
no other help accepted the two of us are
basically forwarding through this
process so um yeah I I hope once the
film is released we may get some
attention and some people read our
scripts and we find funding through
those outlets I think we will do you
think it's an actor's job so promote
their film yeah definitely you do yeah I
mean at least to assist in that you know
not being there yeah I mean depending I
mean at the very least you can let your
friends and family know that it's here
it's here please check it out if you
feel like it you know no so that's the
very least I would say that's probably
their responsibility yeah what if they
don't like it that's a different story
they don't like it then some of the word
like sweep that yeah I mean I get why
people don't promote it prove it it's
hard for me to do that I feel that we've
done in a job to this point I don't
enjoy it all um but like I mentioned
before we don't have any other option at
this point we have to get it out as many
people as possible so that multiple
doors open or at least we have a to walk
through multiple doors um so I get why
people don't promote their film and I
but yeah I mean it for fun like this it
would be nice if every pretty bad
everybody's been great with that and
hasn't been involved in oconomowoc so
that's pretty much I all the examples
like it
think of did do it at least that so yeah
which has been my again it's been we've
been lucky very lucky with the support
not only from the community but from the
cast and crew through all stages of the
process unfailing friends I mean its
host in a way and Sharon and yeah it's
been a while there's a lot of liking
people are I've been pretty encouraging
this is the most money for back in a
week or two to Wisconsin yes we go back
to Wisconsin in a week for the Wisconsin
premiere and Milwaukee and then we have
total of six screens in Wisconsin and
then hopefully one in Chicago which we
sought to confirm or waiting to confirm
and then we'll continue to book there
are a couple other ones that we're
waiting to hear back from and various
dates so we'll see but anyone can follow
on the website and all those will be
listed all the screenings and and
available platforms to see the film on
VOD so may first VOD that may first so
yeah we're excited I mean we're new toys
we don't really know what's going on
other than you know what we've learned
so I know that's ridiculous thing that
said yeah it's been fun and I miss you
so much um where I to be honest I just I
want to get through this hopefully
people enjoy it so that we can continue
to work on the writing directing some
Thai raphy side and producing is hard
yeah definitely liked working on on the
from oconomowoc it was awesome yeah if I
want to do it again yeah so probably
that opportunity if not expect
occurrence do you think too though it
was a family environment and so that's
what's also so special do you think
about what could happen if you to get
other projects but
yeah we can talk about that afternoon
because there are we who knows Dan yeah
i mean i would imagine that as soon as
some people are paid pretty much
everybody has to be paid then the normal
dynamic just completely changes its the
shared goal that brings everybody
together and the more invested they are
in that personally the more they
identify with the goal it's that's
really what makes it work you know so as
soon as you kind of get into the this is
the compensation is money or any other
thing it kind of changes that i think i
would imagine I don't know from
experience play yeah I mean yeah we're
definitely interested to see what
happens um but you can still have a
shared goal if you're getting paid so
direct deposit yeah that is yeah I'm
excited to see how things turn out I
mean like I said it's we did it for
several reason and several reasons and
one of the reasons you know life's short
mmm as well try to do what you want if
you and not saying that this is disabled
if we don't get paid but uh um yeah it's
it's been worth it we've learned a lot
it's exciting to you know so people are
on board and and we you know some people
want to see it some people don't like it
some people like it and but at least
we're getting some positive feedback so
it's exciting to see or to wonder about
what's going to happen next so yeah I
and it's it's it's funny to me yeah yeah
it's definitely it's interesting to hear
people respond to two to your film like
whether they like it or they don't like
it that's such an odd
thing because it's so different there's
so many different reasons but yeah oh
hopefully enough people like it that we
need a shot to make another one which I
think we will good then the date is it
really matter if they like it you got to
realize no you guys realize it been sort
of festering your mind for five years or
so yeah I mean of course it's great if
some people like but I don't mean I
don't think either of us need people to
like it that we didn't make it for first
of people what are needing people to
like it but with the purpose of people
liking it um it'd be great if enough
people liked it enough to rent it no
well yeah of course I mean we and come
see it in the theater you know I'm a we
made it because we had to um i would i
would have never forgiven myself I
didn't like it yeah just like you did
enough to tell other people about it was
really the key I think you know yeah
they have for sure whatever whatever
gets it out there and um hopefully
people hopefully uh like I said well
hopefully an opportunity to make it
you